Now, I'd like to share with you some information about Mardi Gras traditions.
We'll start off with the hurricane,...
...which is probably the most famous cocktail of the French Quarter.
It's a fruit punch-based drink with light rum...
...and we usually garnish it with oranges and cherries.
So during Mardi Gras in the French Quarter you'll see quite a bit of this.
The king cake is also another big tradition.
It symbolizes Kings Day which is usually January 6...
...and signals the beginning of the Mardi Gras season.
The colors traditionally associated with Mardi Gras are purple, green and gold.
Purple represents justice, green represents space and gold represents power,...
...and are traditionally representative of the three wise men that found the baby Jesus.
And inside the cake, there is usually a little plastic infant.
And whoever gets the cake with the infant inside...
...usually has to throw the next king cake party.
Parades are really big for Mardi Gras.
Usually people are parading around in satin costumes,...
...and are throwing throws,...
...usually beads and doubloons in the different Mardi Gras colors.
And then the second line dance is probably one of the most well-known traditions.
People will parade around the floats with umbrellas.
And that signifies into the parade.
Laissez les bons temps rouler.
Let the good times roll.
Grab your hurricane, your Mardi Gras beads, your king cakes and your good friends,...
...and have a happy Mardi Gras.